hello in this video i explain to you in
a simple way
what an anova is and how you can
calculate it
to be precise it is about the simplest
form of the anova
the one-way anova and that's where we
start first
why do we need an anova at all or what
does an anova do
analysis of variance checks whether
there is a statistically
significant difference between more than
two groups
thus the analysis of variance is the
extension of the t-test for independent
samples
to more than two groups in the
independent t-test
we looked at whether there is a
difference or more precisely a
difference in means
between two groups for example there's a
difference
in salary between men and women
in this case we have two groups the
men's group
and the women's group if we want to
compare
more than two groups we use the analysis
of variance
the addition in the t-test for
independent samples
is the same as it the addition and the
analysis of variance
without repeated measurements in the
t-test we used
an independent t-test if the two groups
or samples
are completely independent for example
if one person in this group has nothing
to do
with a person in this group exactly the
same now applies
to the analysis of variance without
repeated measures
except that here we have at least three
independent samples
we would have dependent samples for
example
if the same person in a group were
interviewed at
several points in time then we would use
an analysis of variants with repeated
measures
but now let's look at a few examples a
classic application for analysis of
variance
is in therapy research for example you
might be interested
in whether different therapies result in
different therapeutic successes
the question could be is there different
in the therapeutic success
after a slipped disk of different
therapies
on the one hand you can discuss with
patients which movements are good
and which movements are bad for a
slipped disc
then you can treat one group with
medication and
with the last group you can do
stretching and strength training
at the end of the therapy you could then
investigate the success
and calculate with the help of the anova
whether there is a significant
difference
between the three forms of therapy
and now an example for marketing as a
founder of data tab
i might be interested in whether there
is different in age
between people who are using data tab
spss
or r for this i take a random sample of
people who use
statistical software and ask them which
statistical software they are using and
how old they are
so i have the group of people who use
data tab as a statistical software
spss and r and i want to know
if there's a difference in age among
these groups
i have only taken three groups but of
course you could use also
more groups what exactly is a research
question and an anova
the question is is there a difference in
the population
between the different groups of the
independent variable
in relation to the dependent variable
don't worry
we will go through the sentence briefly
you are probably wondering
why population what is the independent
variable
and what is the dependent variable the
independent variable is a variable with
a different
categories so in our example it is the
therapy type
with a group which learns the right
behavior for a slipped disk
the therapy with medication and the
strength therapy
in the second example the independent
variable is a statistical software used
with the groups data tab spss and r
the dependent variable in our example
was the success
of the therapy and the age we would like
to know
whether the groups of the independent
variables have an
influence on the dependent variable
therefore for our two example
the questions would be is there a
difference between the different
types of therapies in terms of the
therapy success
or is there a difference between the
users of different
statistical software solutions in terms
of age
now the last point why population
actually we want to make a statement
about the whole population
unfortunately in most cases it is not
possible to survey the whole population
and we can only draw a random sample
the aim is to make a statement about the
population
based on the sample with the help of an
anova
of course we did not carry out the
experiment on therapy success
with all peoples who have a slipped disk
but only with a random sample but we
would like
to generalize the statement for the
population
therefore we use the anova and check
whether the result is significant
or not now we have understood this
we move to the hypotheses
before you calculate an anova of course
you have to make the hypothesis
in the case of the analysis of variance
the null hypothesis
is that there are no difference between
the means
of the individual groups we have our
groups
of which we can calculate the mean in
each case
and our null hypothesis is now that
there's no difference in the mean
in the population the alternative
hypothesis
is that there is a difference between
the group means
in other words there is a difference in
the mean between the groups
therefore our null hypothesis says that
there is no difference
and the alternative hypothesis says that
there is a difference
all well and good now we know what the
null hypothesis are
but what does it mean exactly
let's say we want to test whether
there's a difference in the salary
between
these three groups group 1
group 2 and group 3. now of course the
salary has some variance
some people earn 500 views a month
other earn 2 600 euros a month or
some people earn 6 000 euros a month so
both in the population
and in our sample there is a variance in
the salary
now the question is where does the
variance come from
and can we explain some of these
variations by the three groups
so how much of the variation in the
salary can we explain
by dividing the people into these three
groups
in the extreme case the results could be
that the salary in group
one is distributed like this
in the second group like this and in the
third group
like this in this case the division into
the groups
could explain a lot of variance in the
variable
salary we have only a small variation in
each group
the result would be different in this
case here we would again have the
variable salary
and would divide it among three groups
here however we could explain
almost no variance by forming the three
groups
within the groups the variance is almost
as the same
as in the whole sample so it does not
matter
whether we form the groups or not
therefore the three groups have no
influence
on the salary if we now look at the
variants
within the groups we can see that in
this case
there's a low variance within the groups
and
in this case there's a high or large
variance
within the groups if we look at the
variance between groups
we have a large variance between the
groups in this case
so the means of the groups are far away
and we have a small variance between the
groups
in this case here the means of the
groups are not far away
now of course you want to know how you
can calculate an analysis of variance
there are two possibilities for the
calculation either you can use
statistical software like data tab or
you calculate the analysis of variance
by hand
to be honest no one will calculate the
analysis of variance by hand
but the knowledge is very useful to
understand more precisely
how an analysis of variance works in
this video
i show you how you can easily calculate
an analysis of variants online with data
tab
to do this just open datatab.net and
click on the statistics calculator
if you want to use your own data you
simply need to clear the table
and put your data into this table i will
use the example data
because we want to calculate an anova we
simply click on
anova and now you need to select
which variable or which variables you
want
to analyze for the anova we need one
metric variable and one categorical
variable
with at least three components so let's
say
we click on salary and we use
the variable place the place has
three categories new york chicago and
washington
and now you can see here the result of
the anova
in this case probably the assumptions
for an anova are not fulfilled
so you can also calculate the
non-parametric test
instead of the anova
but let's stay with anova so here you
can see the results
and here you can read the p-value
if you like you can also simply click on
summary in words
and you will get the results in words a
one factor
analysis of variance has shown that
there is a significant
influence between the categorical
variable place
and the variable salary okay now we know
how to calculate an anova online with
data tab
i hope you like this video and see you
soon
bye
you